Зі святкового столу - на пікет. Деякі медики планують розпочати новий рік зі страйку,
вимагаючи підвищити зарплату. А опозиційні політики та експерти б’ють на сполох,
стверджуючи, що українські лікарні та аптеки з 1 січня отримають від держави… нуль коштів.
Урядова програма "Доступні ліки", запроваджена понад три року тому,
передбачає, що пацієнти з серцево-судинними захворюваннями, бронхіальною астмою,
діабетом ІІ типу та ще низкою хронічних захворювань
можуть отримати ліки безкоштовно або з незначною доплатою.
Тепер це під загрозою.
За словами народної депутатки з профільного комітету Верховної Ради Ольги Стефанишиної,
з нового року лікарні залишаться без фінансування, а пацієнти без доступних ліків.
Бо досі не затверджено порядок реалізації програми медичних гарантій на перший квартал наступного року.
Тобто 9 тисяч аптек, 7 тисяч лікарень просто залишаться без коштів.
Національна служба зазначає, що їм потрібно 2-3 тижні лише для того, щоб перезаключити угоди.
У нас уже не залишилося часу, і фактично сьогодні міністр, не виносячи цю постанову,
наражає на колапс медичну систему.
Справа в тому, що в тій пропозиції, яка була передана Національною службою здоров’я України,
було запропоновано скасувати, в тому числі деякі "ковідні" пакети,
і залишити в наступному році, наприклад, екстренку без ковідного пакету.
Наприклад,скасувати мобільні бригади, які беруть ПЛР-тести,
наприклад, скасувати доплати медичним працівникам.
Щодо укладання і переукладання відповідних угод, я не думаю,
що на це потрібно стільки часу, як про це говорить Національна служба здоров’я України.
Нацслужба здоров’я подала відповідний проєкт постанови до Мінохоронздоров’я ще місяць тому,
але до порядку денного уряду цей документ так і не потрапив.
Опозиція обвинувачує в цьому особисто Степанова.
Він закиди на свою адресу відкидає й обіцяє найближчим часом таки розглянути доопрацьовану постанову.
Бюджетом на 2021 рік передбачено, що медицина отримає понад 160 мільярдів гривень.
Це більше, ніж у 2020-му, але цифрами маніпулюють.
Влада стверджує, що це на 40 відсотків більше, а опозиція - що лише на 20
і що таке зростання значно менше, ніж, приміром, на утримання Офісу президента, ГПУ чи СБУ.
Праві, по суті, і ті, й інші. Минулого року витрати на охорону здоров'я передбачалися у розмірі113 мільярдів гривень.
Порівняно з цією сумою закладені в бюджет на 2021-ий 160 мільярдів - справді 40 відсотків збільшення.
Але у квітні були схвалені зміни до держбюджету-2020, і в оновленому кошторисі сфері охорони здоров’я
додали ще16 мільярдів гривень - враховуючи цю доплату грошей стане більше не на 40, а лише на 20 відсотків.
Але лікарям і пацієнтам від такої математики не легше. Медицина далі залишатиметься недофінансованою,
особливо з огляду на пандемію коронавірусу.
Зокрема недостатньо грошей передбачено для закупівлі вакцин від COVID-19.
Саме на щеплення роблять ставку західні країни у боротьбі проти коронавірусу.
В Україні ж на вакцинацію передбачено лише два з половиною мільярди гривень.
За оцінками експертів, це вдвічі менше, ніж потрібно.
Україна, звісно, розраховує отримати безкоштовно 8 мільйонів доз вакцин
у рамках програми COVAX, але коли це буде - точно невідомо.
До того ж, цього буде достатньо для вакцинації лише чотирьох мільйонів українців.
А для того, щоб виробився колективний імунітет, потрібно охопити щонайменше 65 відсотків населення.
Попри зміну трьох міністрів охорони здоров’я, президента та численних спроб згорнути медичну реформу, вона продовжується.
З першого квітня стартував другий етап - вже на рівні вторинної,
тобто спеціалізованої медичної допомоги, у лікарнях та поліклініках.
Скільки лікарня пацієнтів пролікує - стільки коштів й отримає від Національної служби здоров’я України.
Це робиться для того, щоб спонукати поліклініки та інші заклади надавати якісні послуги.
Якщо пацієнт пішов до іншого лікаря, щоб зробити операцію, то інший лікар й отримає гроші.
Прив’язки до району чи міста більше нема.
Щоправда, цей етап медреформи співпав з пандемією коронавірусу,
тож його реалізація значно пригальмувалася.
2021-ий покаже, чи вдасться довести медреформу до кінця.
Чи, як застерігають деякі політики, МОЗ Степанова може ще повернути старий "радянський" метод
оплати медпослуг через субвенції - тобто, по суті, в ручне управління мінохоронздоров’я.